i mentioned yesterday on this show that
the impeachment trial
of donald trump i'm sorry the second
impeachment trial of donald trump
was not going to be the end of this
left-wing onslaught that we've seen in
particular over the last four years
that in fact this is the beginning of
something because trump is not
their intended victim what the left is
aiming at
is all of us anyone who would conserve
anything
about american history well this new
trial
is already a beginning a lot of
prominent people on the left
are calling explicitly for a trial of
sorts
to reframe our entire national
self-understanding
for instance representative sarah jacobs
who's calling for a
truth commission to reframe american
history
so i think part of what we're seeing now
is because we haven't really done the
reckoning with
the racial injustice and white supremacy
of our past
that we need to do and so you know a
truth commission
a lot of people will think of south
africa we've used them in countries
around the world
and basically what it is is it's uh
communities all the way up to the
national level
having conversations about both the
glory and the glory of our history and
what happened
both throughout the history of our
country and leading up to and on january
6th
so that we can come to a common
narrative moving forward of what we want
our country to be
and so i think that there are a lot of
us who know that this impeachment trial
was just
the start of holding donald trump
accountable but that we need to make
sure that we're doing accountability of
anyone who incited encouraged or
committed acts of violence
and then really looking forward at kinds
of things like truth commissions
like democracy like institution building
that we know are going to be the real
fixes to what we've seen in this country
to what we've seen in this country
everything that we've seen in this
country up until now which the left
is absolutely rejecting they want a new
sort of country not just aimed at trump
but aimed at any of us
who would conserve that sort of thing
a reframing of the narrative and if you
don't get on board with that reframing
well by golly
you're gonna get blacklisted i'm michael
knowles that's the michael knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the michael knowles show
my favorite comment yesterday is from
sad face
who says i hear after the third
impeachment you get one free
i think that's true and by the way you
might be joking
about that third impeachment but by the
logic of this
impeachment trial there's really no
reason that they couldn't impeach trump
again
probably they'll impeach him again at a
certain point you know
donald trump will have lived his life
he'll be gone they'll probably dig him
up
and put him on trial again because they
are litigating something that is not
about the trump administration
it's about the american country it's
about our nation
and it's about anybody who would
conserve anything
about it they're saying this openly now
people like
this democratic congress lady and many
others
they're not just going after trump it
was probably the most insightful moment
of trump's 2020 campaign he posted that
meme
which said they're not coming after me
they're coming after you and i
happen to be in the way and when they're
coming after you you should probably
anonymize what you're doing on the
internet you should probably not hand
them over
all of your data that's why you've got
to check out expressvpn
big tech companies have a ton of power
in our country right now and you know
they're private companies they don't
they're not really private companies but
because they can claim to be private
companies
they can do just about anything they
want and they're interested in your data
and they're taking your data
do not leave yourself vulnerable you've
got to protect yourself
with express vpn i know what you're
thinking because it's the same thing i
used to think
no one's after my data oh come on
they're not after me
they are they are obviously if you're
listening to this show right now you
probably
you know you look at some things that
are not so savory on the internet you
maybe you
open the incognito window you go to
dailywire.com think you know what i'm
talking about okay
you don't want people who don't like you
to be trying on that kind of information
go to expressvpn.com michael you will
get
three extra months free on a one-year
package that is e-x-p-r-e-s-s-vpn.com
michael to get three months for free
what is that url expressvpn.com
michael seriously do not leave yourself
vulnerable to people who do not like
what you stand for
and what you are supporting head on over
to express
vpn jonathan chait
a very prominent liberal writer not a
writer that i particularly
enjoy reading but every so often he'll
he'll
make a comment that contradicts the
broader left-wing narrative and he did
this uh
just over the past few days with regard
to gina carano who is my
newest colleague at the daily wire gina
carano is an actress
she was in the mandalorian show at
disney disney fired her
for simply being conservative that was
it they
barely even contrived an excuse they
slandered her
said that she made anti-semitic comments
she never never did any such thing
and they canned her so now she's going
to be working with us that's great
one way to push back against cancel
culture and the new blacklist in
hollywood
john chait is admitting there is a
blacklist
in hollywood against conservatives who
contradict the liberal narrative now
we've known this for a very long time
anyone who's spent any even fleeting
time in hollywood knows this is true
in many ways the daily wire was formed
out of a super duper secret
conservative hollywood group called
friends of abe so secret it has a
wikipedia page
friends of abe was a group that was real
you know back when it was running it's
sort of defunct now but was a terrific
organization
where conservatives who were actors
directors writers
uh producers people behind the scenes
gaffers all sorts of people in hollywood
who were not liberals met up to have
some political fellowship and the name
came from
an allusion to being the friends of
abraham lincoln because
back decades and decades ago if you were
a homosexual
and you you wanted to hang out with
like-minded people
you you would use the euphemism friend
of dorothy you'd say instead of saying
i'm openly gay you'd say oh he's a
friend of dorothy
and so if you're a conservative in
hollywood you say now i'm a friend of
abe
because today in hollywood of course
it's
far more likely to face professional
repercussions for being a conservative
than for being gay
right to be celebrated now if you're if
you can claim some kind of
intersectional identity
because intersectionality has now taken
over so much
of our national conversation it's even
affecting the us military which we'll
get to a little bit later
but if you're conservative you will lose
jobs there's no question about this and
and john
jonathan chait is saying there is a
hollywood blacklist this is the new
mccarthyism this is very bad
now i'm pleased that jonathan shade is
acknowledging something that
is really happening and as i've
mentioned before with
regard to terms like cancel culture it's
obviously true there is a phenomenon
going on right now
where you will get your reputation
destroyed
your livelihood destroyed your career
taken from you if you contradict the
politically correct
left-wing narrative however
in another sense this is false in
another sense this is not the new
mccarthyism
because politics has
form and substance what i mean by that
is
the new hollywood blacklist which
absolutely exists against conservatives
is like mccarthyism or the red scare as
people called it which
i think is the silliest term for it
because you know the red scare sort of
implies that there weren't really
communists running around in the country
in high positions and
actually there were which which gets to
my further defense of for instance the
house committee on
american activities and some of what
senator mccarthy did
but in form they're similar right you've
got a professional repercussions
for people on the basis of their
political activities
in in that in that way it's totally the
same the
secret communists of the 1940s and 50s
were punished for their political
activities and regular old american
conservatives
were punished for their political
activities today inform
the same thing but in substance they're
completely different
because on the one hand you had these
communists often working
directly for the soviet union or only
slightly removed from the soviet union
uh the nation with whom we were at war
for the entire cold war
and in the modern sense in hollywood
you've got people who like donald trump
or you got people who like the
constitution or you like got people who
like
george washington or thomas jefferson or
abraham lincoln those are not the same
things
and to punish people for engaging in
activities that would promote the soviet
union and american communism
is not the same thing as promoting
george washington and abraham lincoln
and conservatives have fallen into this
trap for so
long for decades now where we have only
a formal politics we only talk about
procedure
we only talk about the shape of politics
we don't talk about the substance
i think i'm going to go out on a limb
but it's the same limb that ronald
reagan and william f buckley jr and
basically every conservative until five
minutes ago would have gone out on and
said
it is good to cancel communists it is
good that we destroyed the career of for
instance
alger hiss who was a soviet spy working
at very senior levels
of the federal government helped to form
the united nations there were many other
people
like algierhis if you want to read a
good book on that you can read witness
by whitaker chambers one of the books
that turned ronald reagan from a liberal
into a conservative i think that's good
i think if you go out and you say i hate
america i hate george washington i hate
everything our country stands for
and i want to overturn that system if
you say that
you should be canceled that's a good
thing i don't want
people subverting our entire country in
the american way of life
be it in the universities be it in
hollywood or be it
in our government it's so funny now
because the way this is taught in
schools is just mccarthyism you know
that's a perfectly universal terrible
thing mccarthyism or sometimes you'll
hear
huak the house un-american activities
committee
but you only really ever hear these
terms from critics of
those activities from people who are
sympathetic to the communists of the
1940s and 50s
and today by the way but what's
interesting is if you go back at the
time and read documents in support
of these committees which by the way
lasted a very long time i mean similar
committees existed
well into the 1970s you don't hear hugh
ack you hear
the house committee on un-american
activities but they flip it the critics
of it flip it they conflate it with
mccarthyism which of course is very
different right mccarthy was a senator
hugh ack or hcua was part of the house
but we've only got a history written
from these these critics i think we need
to get
much more serious about this and start
talking about the particulars
not just is it good to ever have
repercussions for things we say
of course of course we live in a world
where you have consequences for things
you say
founding fathers knew that and everyone
else with two brain cells to rub
together knows that too
but what are we saying you know if the
house committee on non-american
activities were around today
they would have to haul senior white
house officials
before that committee to ask them why
they're engaging in such
un-american activities take for instance
jensaki the
the poor beleaguered white house press
secretary who was asked what what the
opinion of the white house was
on mark cuban's decision to ban the
national anthem from his basketball
games
this is a layup this should be a simple
q if you ask a politician hey
either party at least until very
recently hey what do you think about
these people disrespecting the american
flag in the national anthem
this is an easy one to say i'm against
it i
i support the national anthem i love the
american flag and apple pie simple
simple answer but now we live in a
country that's been so
eroded and corroded spiritually
politically
that the white house is taking the side
of people
who would ban the american flag what
does president biden think about the
dallas mavericks owner
mark cuban deciding to indefinitely stop
playing the national anthem before
his national basketball association
games well i
i haven't spoken with the president
about the decision by mark cuban on the
dallas mavericks
or the i should say the national anthem
but i know he's incredibly proud to be
an american
and has great respect for the anthem and
all that it represents
especially for our men and women serving
in uniform around the world
he'd also say uh that of course that
part of the
of pride in our country means
recognizing moments where we as a
country haven't lived up to our highest
ideals which is uh
often uh and at times what people are uh
speaking to
when they take action at sporting events
and it means respecting the right of
people
granted to them in the constitution to
peacefully protest that's why he ran for
president
in the first place and that's what he's
focused on doing every day
so joe biden totally supports the flag
in the national anthem
except when america doesn't live up to
her ideals well no country ever lives up
to her ideals because it's a fallen
finite imperfect world so so
she's saying oh joe biden he loves the
national anthem he loves the flag except
he hates the flag and he hates the
national anthem and it's great that
that our sports leagues would and sports
teams rather
would ban the american flag
joe biden says this because he's an old
old politician
who remembers the old way of doing
things but he's an empty suit who's
beholden to
the political winds of his party and the
political winds are now
no longer just against this candidate or
against this policy they are
fundamentally against the country
they're trying to in the words of the
1619 project at the new york times
reframe american history in the words of
this crazy democrat congresswoman
calling for a truth commission
they're trying to reframe the narrative
that the country is bad and we've got to
do
something different that radical point
of view now has an audience and a
supporter all the way up
at the highest office in the land
very very bad stuff if you want to
put a pause on this if you want to fight
back against
this rewriting of american history gotta
check out prageru you know how much i
love prageru
prageru is not just an affiliated
organization
not just you know we have a lot of
friends in the conservative movement
here at the daily wire
prayer you is a little more special
because you've probably seen all of the
daily wire hosts
in prageru videos at various times i
host a show on prageru called the book
club
the america we love is slipping away
are we going to just let the left get
away with it
or are we going to do something about it
prager university foundation better
known
as prageru is a non-profit media
powerhouse
you've probably seen us i hope you've
seen us in various prageru entities
definitely go check out the book club
show which i host there if you haven't
yet
if you want to help save america go to
prageru.com
dailywire prageru's videos are watched 4
million times every single day
more than 70 percent of viewers say
their minds were changed after watching
that's the key there and by the way more
than 60 percent of those viewers
are young they're leading the charge
against big tech censorship they're
they're fighting for our voices to be
heard far and wide they're on the front
lines
of the culture war every single day and
they need you
to help fit everybody out for that fight
if you want to be sure that your
donation dollars will be used to support
your values go to prageru.com
daily wire the left really
doesn't like us now this this doesn't
seem like a groundbreaking insight here
but
it's actually something that
conservatives i think still haven't made
their peace with
there are still many conservatives like
like for instance those loser
squishy republicans who voted to convict
at the farce impeachment trial
but and many other people who maybe
aren't quite as bad as they are but
but who believe that you know ah the
left they just hate trump's tweets if he
weren't so mean they'd be they'd like us
more
if we just tone our rhetoric in a
certain way if we
disavow certain republicans then we can
come together
we'll meet in the middle there is no
middle there is no middle
right now you know this i think is why
joe biden is so confused as joe biden
was always
a moderate democrat that's how he styled
himself because it was
for his political interest to style
himself a moderate democrat
that no longer works so he's embracing
the radical left of the democratic party
when you've got say a moderate democrat
and republicans you can kind of meet in
the middle
why well you're going to disagree on
abortion
right and that's abortions are kind of a
binary issue right either you think we
ought to kill babies in the womb or
or not kill babies in the womb but you
know they're there
there's going to be some compromise
where abortion maybe it'll be legal
until a certain
date or under certain circumstances i
don't want there to be compromise but
but at least it is possible to
compromise in that regard on immigration
well you'll let this many people in but
not this many people and you can
compromise
something like that tax rates well it's
not going to be quite as high as the
democrats want it's not going to be
quite as low as the republicans want
they'll meet in the middle somewhere
foreign trade right whatever you go down
all the list
you can do that with moderate democrats
who agree at the very least this is a
good country we support our country
but you can't do that with radical
democrats
who support political violence and
embrace it
it's funny that the left accuses trump
of supporting political violence
he doesn't do that right he explicitly
said be peaceful don't be violent always
be peaceful
whereas the left does explicitly endorse
political violence
as i feel the trump legal team showed
quite well during
during their video presentation at the
impeachment trial
you can't compromise between one
political party
the republicans who support the country
and one political party that doesn't
support the country
that doesn't support the idea of the
country that doesn't support the symbols
of the country like the american flag
that doesn't support the national anthem
that calls for half the country to be
utterly excised and ostracized
because what's where what is the
compromise between have a country don't
have a country where
how do you meet in the middle you have
you have a city state i don't know
what do you have you meet in the middle
and you have a
an ngo i don't what do you where you
can't you can't compromise between those
things one side is going to win either
we have a country
with borders and loyalty to our fellow
citizens
and some shared sense of purpose or we
don't
we don't have borders we don't have a
common language we don't have any shared
sense of purpose
we hate our history and if you hate your
history guess what you're going to hate
your future too
it's not just about trump the left
feels this way about all of us
chen kuger who's very prominent
left-wing commentator he runs the young
turks he just
showed this today he tweeted out
something that i thought was incredibly
stupid
and revealing true of much of jenk's
commentary he said quote
there are many things trump got right
about right-wing voters
they don't care about policy they're
driven mainly by fear and hatred of
others they're greedy incredibly selfish
and driven mad by envy
and lastly they prefer violence to
democracy if democracy
means equality
might i obviously this is not true the
charges are not true
republicans care a lot about a lot of
policies we want to make abortion
illegal we want to have stable families
we want to be able to keep more of our
property we want to
close up our borders and have a
functioning nation we want to keep
national sovereignty
away from transnational institutions
where there are a lot of things i mean
we could go down the list right so those
are policies on that he's just
flat out wrong there what's he say he
says that we're selfish
uh we're selfish in that we're human all
humans are selfish to a degree but
in fact conservatives propose a politics
ordered toward higher goods
right generally speaking
uh maybe the libertarians a little bit
less so but uh the conservatives
generally
supported politics ordered toward a
higher good
a transcendent moral order that maybe
limits some of my appetites and desires
but ultimately it's for a higher good
uh conservatives are not particularly
envious right on the contrary
what did winston churchill call
socialism he said was the gospel of envy
conservatives say we ought to be able to
keep the things that are ours the left
is saying
we want what is yours give me what is
yours i deserve
that which you already have are
conservatives violent well
they can be violent i suppose but much
less violent than the left
compare the three-hour madness of the
capital riot compared to the
six-month-long blm and antifa riots even
longer than that
and moreover on this equality question
conservatives embrace a far
deeper and more substantive vision of
equality than liberals
the left right now is is has created a
new caste
system whereby people have greater or
lesser value
based on their race based on their sex
based on their sexual desires
based on various claims of grievance
conservatives don't say that we say no
we have a sort of spiritual equality and
a political equality as citizens
and uh and that's that we obviously are
different physically we look different
some people are taller shorter
but we do have this kind of spiritual
and political equality the left and not
basically denies the spiritual equality
through the various ideologies that they
entertain which are overwhelmingly
materialist or or even worse
but more than this tweet being wrong
it's extremely stupid
just imagine dedicating your career to
political commentary and this is the
best you can muster
the right wing is bad trump got right
they're bad they're evil they're
terrible
i i really would hope for better from
our left-wing commentators that's why i
began the show talking about jonathan
shaite
who i don't really like but occasionally
says something that's at least
interesting at least unexpected i don't
think that the left is uniformly driven
by fear and hatred and
they don't care about policy and their
greedy and all sure i mean
that stuff exists but i think that the
left is motivated by ideas
i think generally speaking maybe not
chenk i don't know how you know he
doesn't have too much going on in
between the ears
but i think there are many leftist
intellectuals
who shape the ideas that drive the left
and i think those ideas are bad
and i think their motivations are
suspect
and i think their moral vision is
perverse
but i do want to take those ideas
seriously try to work through them in
fact
in many ways my book that i i just have
coming out speechless controlling words
controlling minds available now for
pre-order
the whole point of the book is to take
the left's ideas seriously and say this
is actually
kind of interesting and maybe we can
learn from this and this is completely
wrong but here's what it led to and you
know take that seriously
chunk doesn't want to take any of this
seriously the left
broadly right now i think doesn't want
to take any of us seriously
they just want to write off half the
country and re-educate us
and have truth commissions and bar us
from running for office like they tried
to do
with the impeachment force it's not just
[ __ ] uber it's not just some
dumb you know sort of shallow thinking
left-wing commentator who whose every
other word is a is a
some sort of profanity because his
vocabulary isn't particularly
large it's also the elected democrats
like for instance
ilhan omar the decisions
um sadly that the republican party has
made
was a calculation based on power
and violence being more valuable to them
than
protecting this democracy what we saw in
this week's impeachment trial were
nearly every single
senate republican voted to block even
the consideration of charges against
trump
tells us everything that we need to know
tells us everything we need to know they
prefer
violence and power to democracy
i won't rehash the obvious hypocrisy
here which is that
the democratic party has openly
explicitly embraced
violence right in their rhetoric kamala
harris bailed the violent
rioters out of out of jail during the
george floyd riots
they went back onto the street so
obviously you know they're accusing us
of things that they do
but but moreover forget the violence
thing for a second
forget even the power thing frankly i
think republicans are not that
interested in in power we don't know how
to use political power when it's given
to us
we squander our political power because
we're too cowardly
to offer a substantive vision of
politics say what you will about the
left
they're offering some substance right
they they know what they want at least
on the left conservatives can't really
muster much of a vision at all
so i think the the left certainly better
at power but i want to focus in on
democracy
because you'll notice when it comes to
the left it's only democracy
when the people support the left when
when
the people do not support the left when
say they vote for trump by accident you
know in 2016 somehow he gets through
well that's neces by definition
illegitimate
like that that somehow was a perversion
of distortion
of democracy the left constantly
outsourcing
so many of our so many of our political
rights to these technocrats these
unaccountable bureaucrats who run our
lives
for us you know republicans are putting
forward a pretty interesting
pro-democracy bill
that something tells me ilhan omar and
many democrats will oppose
before we get to that you've got to
check out select quote select quote
comparison shops up
highly rated companies including
prudential ban
banner life mutual of omaha and others
to find you the company with the best
rates
for example select quote could find a 35
year old man
a half million dollar policy for under
19
a month that is less than a dollar a day
a cup of coffee costs more than that
cost significantly more than that
actually
select quotes breakthrough technology
allows them to quickly match you
with the best insurance company to find
your best policy plus the quotes are
free
i know a lot of people they think i
don't need an insurance policy it's not
a big deal
i'm a married man i just had my first
child i want to make sure
as irresponsible as i can be in my life
i want to make sure that they are
protected it's just a responsible thing
to do you want to make sure
that your loved ones are prepared just
go do it it'll give you peace of mind
then peace of mind that's the right
thing to do let's select quote save you
time and money get your free quote at
selectquote.com today
that's selectquote.com for your free
quote don't put off protecting your
family another day
selectquote.com get full details on the
example policy at select quote.com
commercials your premium can vary
depending on your health issuing company
and other factors
not available in all states also
subscribe to the daily wire you should
be
watching and listening to this content
on the daily wire i know there are other
places to do it
apple podcast google play stitcher all
these places
only a matter of time as the left
increases their political persecution of
conservatives it's only a matter of time
before we get kicked off of those places
uh they're they're trying to cancel
people they just tried to cancel the
actress gina carano we hired her
by the way right now if you want to join
daily wire you can
save 25 by using promo code gina go to
dailywire.com subscribe if you want to
stand up
against this new kind of censorship and
political persecution go to
dailywire.com we'll be right back
with a lot more
ilhan omar claims that
the republicans and conservatives are
trying to subvert democracy
i don't think that's true these terms
things like democracy are very broad
terms so i want to bring it down to
earth for a second
but i will make the broad claim i think
conservatives are much more interested
in defending democracy than liberals and
leftists and progressives and whatever
term you want to use
and i'll give you an example of this
that i think throws it into stark relief
down in tennessee
there's a new bill in the tennessee
general assembly
that is trying to create a legal
procedure
by which a man can
prohibit a woman from aborting
his child i love this bill i think this
is a great bill
it's sb0494 in tennessee senate
and hb 1079 in the tennessee house
sponsored by state senator mark capote
and state rep jerry
sexton it quote permits a person to
petition a court for an injunction to
prohibit a woman who is pregnant with
the person's unborn child
from obtaining an abortion we've been
told by the left
men cannot have an opinion about
abortion squishy republicans say this
too
men should not have an opinion this is a
woman's issue it only involves a woman's
body of course that's not true
it involves a baby and that baby by the
way is not just the product of a woman
it's a product of the love between a man
and a woman
it's not just the woman's child that she
would be killing but
the man's child too so i i
sort of would offer the exact opposite
advice that we hear from the left which
is
a man should have no opinion about
abortion i i think a man
should absolutely be able to prohibit an
abortion
if we still have legal abortion which is
unfortunate at the very least the father
should be able to stop a woman from
killing
his child this is very democratic
how is this democratic there's no
one there's no constitutional right to
an abortion there was
an invented fictitional fictitious
constitutional right
from roe versus wade that even honest
liberal jurists will admit is nowhere in
the constitution
when you ask the constitutional scholars
you say where where is it in the
constitution you find that right
they'll say well it's in the emanations
in the penumbras
in between an invisible link between
lines 35 and 36 i
okay i don't really i don't see that in
there of course the constitution doesn't
say anything about abortion
the only thing it maybe could say about
abortion actually is the 14th amendment
which would prohibit abortion right if
by protecting people equal
equal protection but
the question broadly has been left up to
democratic
processes you persuade your fellow
citizens okay we should have abortion
legal abortion or we should not have
legal abortion or we should permit this
kind of abortion okay well that's what's
going on in the tennessee legislature
right now
certainly it would be it's democratic to
allow a man to have a say
over the future of his child in addition
to the woman
adding that say would would be an
increase in democracy would it not
or you have the alternative which is
some robed lawyer on a court invents a
right
and takes away your political freedom to
make a law
now i i hope conservatives get behind
this bill
one because it's pro-democracy or
whatever i just want to show that
illinois is a hypocrite
but also because this is this is
offering some real substance here
oh you're pro-life okay good
then prove it put up or shut up
i i think most of the pro-life activists
probably all pro-life activists would
support it but i i want republicans even
who are moderate on this issue i want
them to get behind this there is no
reason whatsoever
that this bill should not pass in
tennessee
and as the states are laboratories of
democracy no reason why this shouldn't
be tried out elsewhere in the country
we need to stop playing on the terms of
the left we need to stop allowing them
to say well it's a woman's issue well
it's kind of touchy well i don't know
it's a third rail i don't want to touch
it no touch it head on
if we're not willing to say that you
shouldn't kill children
and if we do have a system where you can
kill children at least the dad should be
able to stop it
if we're not willing to say that we're
not willing to say anything
and the left they've already won and we
should just roll over you know
they're promising to persecute
conservatives right now
not just trump at all of us they're
promised i mean the congressmen are
saying this out loud
media figures are saying this out loud
if we're not willing to stand up for
ourselves then let's get it let's have
it be done with you know a lot of people
consider this
a religious issue and you know
it it doesn't necessarily need to be
argued in religious terms you can just
say like hey look there's a
there's a baby in there babies obviously
alive the baby's obviously human
and therefore this raises bioethical
questions and you should support
keeping that baby alive and you should
oppose plans to murder it
but all of these things were argued in
religious terms as cardinal manning
famously said all human conflict
ultimately is theological
when we're arguing about uh i don't know
taxes even we're arguing about
immigration we're arguing about any
political issue
we are proposing ethical
and moral considerations if we're
talking about parking ticket regimes
we're discussing ethics and morality
which has cultural
uh a cultural basis and ultimately a
religious basis that's where it comes
from
so thankfully some of our religious
leaders are starting to take this
seriously
you know that joe biden is a devout
catholic i'm sure you've heard this
he the white house can't say it enough
he's a devout catholic
he's the most radically pro-abortion
president in american history
he was actually denied the eucharist at
a church in north carolina rightly so
because he's so
opposed to the church's teaching on this
fundamental issue
but he's a devout catholic and some
liberal clerics
let him get away with this and it's a
great scandal well there's a bishop
the archbishop of kansas city who's
coming out and saying nah no more we're
not going to do that
archbishop joseph naumann of kansas city
says mr biden professes to be a devout
catholic yet is 100 pro-choice on
abortion
or i'm sorry he was answering this
question how do you think the bishops
should respond he says quote
i can tell you this bishop is going to
respond this way the president should
stop defining himself
as a devout catholic and acknowledge
that his view on abortion is contrary to
catholic moral teaching
it would be a more honest approach for
him to say he disagreed with his church
on this important issue that he was
acting contrary to church teaching
when he says he's a devout catholic we
bishops have a responsibility to correct
him
although people have given this
president power and authority he cannot
define
what it is to be a catholic and what
catholic moral teaching
is what he is now doing is usurping the
role of the bishops and confusing people
absolutely right more
bishops should should speak out in this
way it would be an act of mercy to biden
who is imperiling his soul by carrying
on the way that he has
that's some clear moral teaching and
politics
has a fundamentally moral aspect to it
the left does not have this clarity i
said this is i thought the chunk yogurt
tweet was gonna be the dumbest thing i
saw on the internet for the past several
days
no sean penn you know that brilliant
actor sean penn
he actually is an excellent actor but
he's not a brilliant person
uh he had the dumbest thing i've seen on
the internet in a long time i've read
the new york times recently i've read
the washington post recently
sean penn takes the cake he said quote
evangelical
leaders should themselves be impeached
by the vatican
wait for it if they themselves don't
follow nikki haley's lead
and clearly state they should not have
followed
satin into the bowels of hell but
perhaps they're too busy at sex parties
there are many things wrong with this
tweet first of all
evangelical leaders probably will not be
impeached by the vatican
uh because they are not catholic uh they
don't recognize the authority of the
of the pope or the vatican sean penn
doesn't understand
that there's something called
protestantism they're in catholicism
they're different
uh he then talks about how great nikki
haley is he then misspells
satan's name to satin which makes
you know i suppose satan is the slippery
sort of figure so the images are similar
but
satin much comfier than the father of
lies
and then he gets in this jive at sex
parties the reason i mention it
is is not really to probe sean penn's
deep
religious and political thoughts or the
lack thereof but
to show as ronald reagan once said
it's not what people don't know that
gets them into trouble
it's what they know for certain that
just ain't so
sean penn doesn't know anything people
during the especially during the bush
administration they tried to make sean
pan out to be this
intellectual leader of the left because
he's a good actor so he kind of
looks really intelligent he's got this
kind of squishy smoldering face you know
it's really it seems like he's deep in
thought i think
all that is going on in his head is the
whistling going from
ear to ear i don't think there's a whole
lot going on in there
but he he looks that way and i think
this is true of the left when when the
left is talking about
any topic american history
uh the nature of the regime american
government civics
uh the cultural and moral considerations
they just
not only don't know what they're talking
about but they know so many things that
aren't so
and they're they're offering this kind
of narrative you know
you'll notice they always use this term
narrative that crazy congress lady that
we discussed at the beginning of the
show
who's calling for a truth commission
does this the 1619 project does this
they say we need to reframe the
narrative and
in part the reason that they do this is
because the way we tell stories affects
how politics
will play out but also because
the left seems to have embraced a
radical skepticism
about objective truth you know when they
talk about um intersectionality or
you know lived experiences that's
another term they use
what they're suggesting is or my truth
or your truth or the you know this is
how i feel
what they're saying is that we can't
rely on objective reality there may be
there isn't any such thing as objective
reality
or objective truth it's all just a
social construct
you know there's no men or women it's
all socially constructed
and so the narrative is everything
a lot of this comes from what some kind
of radical academics
during the mid to late 20th century
dairy daw in particular
uh and and some of derrida's followers
will will
uh claim that this is not really what he
meant but he said there's nothing
outside the text
it's a very famous line in this kind of
radical academic movement there's
nothing
outside of the text and what this has
been at least interpreted to mean for
many years is
it's just uh it's all words words words
to use a hamlet's line when he was
feigning madness
it's all just kind of stories and
there's there's no fundamental reality
that it's connected to
so if we change the words we can change
the culture this is
the fundamental premise of political
correctness if we just redefine
reality then reality actually will
change that that is what
we're up against here and and it's why
we kind of argue things a little bit
differently but so what conservatives do
is they say no
these american figures did this they
said this they meant this
we it's not just all being made up in
our minds every day we can't just
redefine history
however we want we're referring to some
reality the left
broadly speaking isn't really playing
that game they're playing a different
game a game of narrative
construction which is why they try to
blot out history tear down statutes
rewrite historical and literary
documents
that have been so influential to our
tradition and the result
is a pretty uh unpleasant
unfortunate for a lot of people you know
there's
there's one very tangible practical way
that left-wing policies
are uh are disrupting people right now
that left-wing fantasies
are hurting people's real lives
what's going on in texas you uh if
you're watching this show on video
you'll see that i'm not in my usual
studio i'm actually at home we've had
snow days
at the daily wire because there's a big
storm in tennessee and the roads are icy
and
they don't want people to come in okay
that's fine this is really
affecting texas all this crazy weather
texas is getting hit with a horrible
winter storm
and compounding that problem
there are rolling blackouts all
throughout the state but the cause of
the blackouts is not just the weather
it's also bad left-wing policies
the overall power input of texas has
declined
pretty significantly after half of the
state's
wind turbines were frozen in a winter
storm over the weekend
parts of texas are now down to zero
degrees fahrenheit
texans are freezing right now more than
two million homes and businesses
have experienced power outages because
the wind turbines froze
why is texas which is you know
basically just a state made of oil
made of fossil fuels why are they
relying on wind turbines
because radical environmentalists
are so afraid of the sun monster that
they say
is going to destroy the world through
global warming within
what what do they say 12 years aoc says
and prince charles said 18 months but he
said it like two years ago so i guess
the world is over already
they're so afraid that global warming is
going to destroy the world that they
reordered texas
texas energy policies and now texans are
freezing
we all it's become sort of cliche to
even say this we could all use a little
global warming right now it's pretty
chilly
well michael weather isn't climate uh
except when it's convenient for us to
say that weather is climate well the
weather conditions have nothing to do
with the climate okay i don't want to
relitigate the climate issue
we'll talk about that some other time
i'm just pointing to the political issue
here
the fantasy of imminent armageddon
because of the sun monster
is leading to insane policies that are
now by the way the way to rectify these
wind turbine issues
is to pour chemicals made with fossil
fuels from
aircraft made from fossil fuels on wind
turbines also made from fossil fuels
you know probably not really great for
the environment to make up
for these policies that were put forward
because
the left is living in a fantasy that is
having very
unpleasant effects in reality
even the united states military is not
immune
from the crazy fantasies of the left i
could not believe this i thought this
was
like a babylon bee or an onion article
this week
but it's not this is real a new report
from the
u.s navy on inclusion and diversity
will uh force these members to pledge
uh to quote advocate for and acknowledge
all
lived experiences and intersectional
identities
of every sailor in the u.s navy
u.s navy exists to kill our enemies
is now talking like some woke
blue-haired chick
on a college campus freshman year the
task force is called task force one navy
it was announced in june
of 2020 and their their uh
role is quote to analyze and evaluate
issues in our society and military
that detract from navy readiness oh okay
so what like you don't have enough ammo
you don't have enough jet fuel for the
planes that are going to fly off of the
aircraft carriers and bomb our enemies
no no no what the task force believes
stops navy readiness is
quote racism sexism and other structural
and interpersonal
biases and to attain significant
sustainable inclusion and
diversity-related reform
that's what's keeping our military from
from
being prepared to take on violent
jihadis
and china the growing growing superpower
here are just some of the pledges that
the committee will have you take
quote as a key member of task force one
navy i will invest the time attention
and empathy
required to analyze and evaluate
navy-wide issues related to racism
sexism ableism interesting consideration
for
the military and other structural and
interpersonal biases
i pledge to be actively inclusive in the
public and private spheres where i
live and work and proactively encourage
others to do the same
i pledge to engage in ongoing
self-reflection
and knowledge i pledge to be an example
in establishing healthy inclusive and
team-oriented environments
i pledge to constructively share all
experiences and information gained from
activities above
to inform the development of navy-wide
reforms xi
jinping must be grinning
from ear to ear reading
that this is the kind of nonsense that
the united states military is spending
its time on
can you imagine the mullahs right now in
iran
can you imagine the belly laughs they're
having reading about how the navy
is spending resources trying to
develop the intersectional lived
experiences
of all the inclusive members of the i
can't even get through it
without getting sick to my stomach how
insane that is
the purpose of the military is to
be really really strong and really
really
focused and kill our enemies that's the
job of the military
but now i guess the purpose is to have
like slam poetry sessions or something
to have
drum circles and talk about our feel
fields are you kidding me
can you imagine putin what putin is
thinking right now oh my gosh
let's you know obviously the democrats
don't want us to have a national border
who cares like if this is the sort of
thing
that that is being implemented from our
political class now even to affect our
military
what's the point of having a border it's
not going to do us very much good
what is the point what is the country
you know one one of the things that we
were promised by by democrats
if they got unified government was that
they would push for puerto rican
statehood they also want to push for d.c
statehood why is it because they
particularly like
puerto ricans is it because they really
don't even understand the purpose of
washington dc maybe that's true but
really what it's for is because those
two places if they became states would
give democrats much more power
the people there would support democrats
we just we just know this given the
political affinities in the areas it
would give
democrats four new senators new members
of congress
new advantages in presidential elections
now that push for puerto rican statehood
is really beginning in earnest here's
the governor of puerto rico
explaining his reasoning for it
what i anticipate is that there'll be uh
considerable support
for um a statehood bill
in this congress diversity is is is
happening
uh all over uh puerto ricans will always
be puerto ricans will be puerto
rican-americans
bilingual is is beautiful uh speaking
more than
than one language is an asset for
anybody so if anything the challenge in
puerto rico
is to make sure that our population ends
up being fluent in both
um spanish and english for their
you know for their well-being these are
very interesting comments actually
because
it shows to me this governor of puerto
rico pedro pierre luisi
actually does understand some of the
questions that are at play here with
puerto rican statehood because beyond
the raw political calculation of
democrats only want it because it's
going to get the more power there is
this question
puerto rico has a distinct culture if
puerto rico becomes a state can that
culture become part of the american
national culture
and what pierloisi says here is
the u.s could be expanded by admitting
puerto rico into the union
it would be telling the world that it is
embracing diversity
because this would be a truly completely
hispanic state
now in a sense that would add to the
diversity of the united states but in
another sense
puerto rico would be the least diverse
state in america
as he says it's a truly completely
hispanic state
we don't have any completely white state
any completely black state any
completely asian or hispanic state
so that so puerto rico would be the
least diverse state in america
but it would add to the diversity of the
country well could it
we don't really even have a common
language i mean obviously many people in
puerto rico speak english but the
predominant language there is spanish
and what he says is well people should
speak both i agree i think it's great to
study languages i love studying
languages
but that cannot be the case if puerto
rico were to be admitted even if i were
to somehow support this they would have
to speak english
they would have to predominantly speak
english they should stop encouraging
puerto ricans to speak spanish
if they want to be part of america
because in america we speak english we
have very little that unites us
one at the very least we need to speak
the same language but the left doesn't
want us to speak the same language
the left wants us to speak very very
different languages
because the left wants to reframe the
country all that was old all that makes
up the country right now the real stuff
of the country
the language the customs the beliefs the
principles the legal system the people
all
that they don't like that they want to
change that
and so now we're in a political battle
not just even for the direction of the
country or a little change here or there
a little evolution not revolution
we're we're in a battle for for the very
character the very fundamental character
of the country
that's the real trial and conservatives
are the ones
that are are going to be facing that
trial and we'll just have to see if
conservatives can stand up to it i hope
they at least understand the game that
we're in
i'm michael moses the michael knowles
show see you tomorrow
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer
jeremy boary our technical director is
austin stevens
supervising producers mathis glover and
robert sterling
production manager pavel vadovsky editor
and associate producer
danny d'amico audio mixer mike coromina
hair and makeup by nikka geneva and
production coordinator mckenna waters
the michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright
dailywire 2021 if you prefer facts over
feelings aren't offended by the brutal
truth and you can still laugh at the
insanity filling our national news cycle
well tune in to the ben shapiro show
we'll get a whole lot of that and much
more
see you there